is the employer that is the one
situation where these payments could
potentially use but then with that
containment we could do an us closure
agreement so that actually then that
would mean that if that that potentially
could mean that we as an employer were
maybe not being a big held to account
for actions which should be being held
to account for so yeah that's why I
struggled to understand and understand
that
you know
it's something that we absolutely need
to have upon this position on this is
our policy position
um it's
there should we want to remove it but
then you know that would be quite
significant reasons why we believe this
positive position
um but yeah let's take some of that
foreign
Council Obama
thank you John just a very simple good
question
um although this policy is new but do we
have any example that where we come to
us
had made any payments
under this policy
I hope not
I haven't got that information
technical question
how often is this document review and
broadcast is committee
so it's relative so that's that would be
good to me
and I think usually if there are many
sort of real changes kind of a refresh
of the policy and we will bring it back
because
Institute unless the Constitution then
changed the levels of approvals that are
in
fact that we're suggesting that we've
used to
align to the policy position so he has
two questions
the levels that we're suggesting
um have the approval completion at the
moment
exactly that's right
and I just wanted to ask on point five
with the the numbers for the approvals
and who who they go to are they
different to previously as in
obviously amount that it would come to
this committee before we have this
policy
policy no so they're pretty much aligned
to their current operating Arrangements
thanks
emergency
[Music]
foreign
service for our adult social care
children social care and mental health
forming statutory responsibility for
local Authority
the supplement will support Recruitment
and attention of Staff during traveling
times nationally with respect to
improved mental health practitioners
apps
emergency Duty team worked solely after
hours to revive the majority Beauty
function
365 days of the year and provide
exceptional staff repair of hours for
our most vulnerable people in the
community
and that we meet that such reviews and
providing amount of hours of service and
language development of Health act 1983
Care Act 2014 and the children's Act of
1989.
there are six EDT social workers at
plantains which is our senior level that
have had a market supplement place since
2019 and then it was reviewed again in
2021.
the current payment is 3
366 pounds per hour
comparison work has been completed
across greater Manchester to see how we
compare a review of The Summer Event
tracking data has taken place which is
outlined in the report
the report confirms that we'll continue
to pay the current market supplement it
would retain staff and our place in the
GM Market
employment committee is recommended to
note the continuation of the payment of
a market supplement 1500
around for over two years with an annual
review as per the policy thank you
any questions
I think it's necessary you know to be
able to recruit
I think position sensible
no grateful
yeah this is probably one of the most
important teams in the local Authority
there there for emergencies it's
qualified social workers who have the
ability to be able to section somebody
if necessary and if that service falls
apart there's goodness knows what kind
of Crisis people will find themselves in
so thank you for that counselor
it brings us sort of somewhere in the
middle doesn't it which feels like a
fairly comfortable place to be in terms
of okay you can Pace levels but
um whether the club there are plans for
a review of the pay levels but the
possibly incorporating a longer term
um incorporation with that market value
market supplement
thank you we obviously will be looking
at
um
to go through the normal process as well
considers
thank you Council care appointments
um
how success was the supplement being
obviously it's very much required until
we've held pathology supported but how
success was as being and how is that
measured
I'm here on behalf of the team and
actually helps with the paint channel so
um
rather than
just
okay
okay thank you
um
you know
this important thank you
now legal Team market supplement
payments thank you chair Amazon legal
and governments I don't propose to
rehearse the content of the report which
I think very much speaks for itself and
very much follows the theme of previous
reports you've considered tonight and
identifies challenges that are relatable
to other services
across the council the difficulties
being experienced in the Recruitment and
Retention of
qualified and experienced lawyers can't
be overstated and I think this is
compounded when you put this into the
context of these significant rates that
are being demanded by agency
staff the report provides the detailed
analysis of the options taken to address
the difficulties we're facing
and recognizes also about the regional
and National position is challenging the
total agency spent for legal equivalence
in the first quarter of this financial
year was in excess of two hundred
thousand pounds and whilst we're
fortunate to be able to attract local
lawyers they now outnumber our permanent
lawyers and this simply isn't
sustainable in the long term for a
number of factors
and this is just the obvious Financial
crashes the current situation houses the
legal teams have experienced a prolonged
period of instability not only for
colleagues within the service but also
for all offices across the camps or
looking relying on our legal advice and
support to fulfill the
public statutory functions
so as a service we are actually
exploring a range of solutions to
address the challenges around
recruitment to retention for an
important part of that is addressing the
attractiveness of the pay offer that we
too want to talk about benchmarking
exercise across GM authorities
uh which demonstrates that we don't
compare favorably as it stands and most
of the GM authorities are internal
offering Market Force supplements so the
report before you this evening sets out
the proposals of the payment are the
market for supplement for two year
period and this will be subject to
review and evaluation as to its impact
on the stabilization of the legal
services Workforce and the committee is
asked to note these recommendations and
I think we can replicate the success
that's been highlighted in the world of
adult social care and they're more
confident we can drive down Nations
expand within the Little Farms but
equally as important we can stabilize
the workforce which will in turn improve
staff engagement and service provided by
our legal teams across the council
an absolutely necessity anything that
can help with the retention of Staff has
to be abroaded thank you for the report
thank you
foreign
[Music]
you know where you sort of highlighted
that
how many times you know the role was
advertising
we have low coming places that the total
number of lawyers you have in the
department
it is page two and three yes thank you I
don't have the figures uh to Hound if
the specific detail work that you would
like I can certainly gather that and
provide it to you outside of this
meeting
okay please thank you
health conditions
um we continue to provide some small
damages
um
yeah I haven't been notified of any
urgent business so in that case I think
we can incorporating closed and thank
you for your attendance